The Japanese are more used to the presence of foreigners among them now,...
...compared to, say, 30 years ago.
There are more than 2.8 million foreigners in Japan...
...as of June 2021.
Compared to the 1990s, the figure has doubled.
As to the size of foreign labor force in Japan,...
...it's shown a steep rise of over three times in the past decade.
The Vietnamese made up 26% of Japan's 1.7 million foreign workers...
...as of October 2021.
Most of them came to Japan under the Technical Intern Training Program.
Vietnamese workers Trong and Huy...
...are hard at work at this construction site...
...in the residential area of Shizuoka City.
They are plastering wallpaper for a clinic, supervised by Japanese craftsman Takeo Ohta.
Trong, the older of the two Vietnamese, told me...
...he's been with the company for the last five years.
Trong and Huy came to Japan through the Technical Trainee Program,...
...which was introduced in Japan in 1993.
Trainees are not required to be fluent in the Japanese language.
The program's initial aim was to bring in interns from developing countries,...
...mostly from Southeast Asia.